in the Pacific Ocean north of the
Equator
there's a growing floating island of
trash that's twice the size of Texas and
three times the size of France it's just
another example of how we're treating
our planet like a dumpster experts say
that every year we throw away enough
plastic to circle the earth four times
at that rate by the year 2025 there'll
be more trash in our oceans than there
are fish so how can we stop being so
wasteful
could we limit everyone's trash to just
one jar per year
should we stop using smart phones or
could we just feed all our waste to
worms this is what if and here's what
would happen if we created no waste
let's start by looking at the idea of
limiting everyone to one jar of waste
per year a mason jar to be precise it
might sound impossible but there's a
whole community of people around the
world who do this they practice zero
waste alternatives like making their
meals from scratch recycling or reusing
all materials and only buying
sustainably produced clothing although
this is probably unrealistic for some
people in the world because of the time
and money involved the ideas behind it
could help us become a waste free planet
how would a world without waste affect
our environment our economy and even our
housing markets the main idea behind
creating no waste is a concept that was
coined in the 1990s called cradle to
cradle it's a simple concept at the core
biological products like food and items
made from natural goods like trees are
utilized until they can no longer be
used in their current forms then they're
broken down in a natural way like
composting to help make new materials
for instance Cradle to Cradle doesn't
mean we can't keep using smart phones it
just means that we have to recycle them
when they break so that their components
can be repurposed for new goods if we
all embraced this idea in our everyday
lives we'd see a reduction of waste on
our planet but we'd never get anywhere
near our zero waste goal if corporations
didn't embrace it as well some companies
are already taking the initiative
they're finding creative ways to make
more sustainable products by recycling
and reusing items or by devising ways to
clean the earth as they make new
products for example adidas has started
to make shoes and other goods from
plastics collected from the ocean and
recycled but our best hope for cleaning
up our act might be Mother Nature
herself her powers were on full display
when the Spanish National Research
Council discovered that wax worms could
eat and digest plastic researchers are
still figuring out how this works but it
could be a breakthrough in helping to
get rid of the plastic in the oceans
who knows how many other groundbreaking
alternatives like this are out there
just waiting to be discovered if more
organizations invest in research like
this we could soon find out and each
alternative we discover could bring us
one step closer to a waste-free society
can you picture it one vision of a more
sustainable future proposed by French
bio designer Julian Graves involves
growing entirely degradable objects like
bandages and chairs from microorganisms
you can learn more about that and other
innovative waste solutions in the
documentary wastes of the future which
you can find on curiosity stream we'll
get back to the story in a second but in
case you don't know
curiosity stream is a video streaming
service with thousands of award-winning
documentaries and the good news is that
has a what-if viewer you get 30 days of
curiosity stream completely free yeah
that's right free after that it's just
$2.99 a month or even better $19.99 a
year it is pretty amazing a lot of their
videos talk about the same topics that
we do here so it's a great place to take
a deeper dive into the subject matter
all you have to do is sign up at
curiosity string comm slash what if and
use the promo code what if all won't
work during the signup process if we
were able to move into a waste-free
future the economy would have to change
as people wouldn't demand or accept as
much plastic or single-use consumer
goods as we currently do there would be
less of a demand for landfill space as
less trash would be created meaning
there would be less waste to dispose of
ideally long-term we'd have cleaner
water cleaner air more trees and we'd
mind fewer metals for use in high-tech
items like smartphones we'd also have
richer Gardens thanks to more compost as
more people would be contributing their
household food waste to community or
personal compost bins buying less stuff
even make people happier and able to
live in smaller homes which could on a
grander scale help to accommodate the
population boom were expecting across
the globe in the next few decades but as
great as this all sounds it would be
very difficult to achieve we need all
the world's nations working together
with one unified vision maybe it would
be easier if we all just combined into
one country but that's a topic for
another what if
[Music]